yeah and now also this all the situation
with the candidate spot and uh today was
also this clarification from F about the
rules what do you think about it and
yeah well actually I had little time for
for all this also it was a bit
surprising as I told you yesterday I
wasn't um I mean I was aware of vaguely
of the idea but uh uh I didn't expect it
to be so close and um and yeah so I I
had time to to check what the uh the
statement put forward by F and I saw
then uh some comments Chris for example
was commenting that uh uh this wasn't in
the original rule so if that's the case
that's of course not great from F but I
I mean again I plan to kind of after the
tournament I you will think about I
think about all this and and see what uh
what what should I do